Professor Robert
Shiller: This is the second
of two lectures from Lawrence
Summers.
Let me just say,
again, this is the Okun Lecture
Series created by an anonymous
donor in honor of Arthur Okun.
At the last lecture,
I was very pleased to hear the
number of fond memories that
Larry Summers has of Arthur
Okun.
At today's lecture,
I think some people felt that
we didn't have enough time for
question and answer,
so we plan to allocate a half
hour to that.
Does that sound good?
Larry will wrap up just before
the hour and we'll have a good
discussion.
Professor Larry Summers:
Judging by the discussions I had
an opportunity to have at lunch
and dinner,
I would suggest a proposal for
you, Bob, with respect to next
year's Okun lecturer.
Invite the Okun lecturer to
give his first lecture,
then let him have dinner and
let him have lunch with the Yale
faculty;
then, let him ponder what he's
been told for three weeks and
invite him to come back and
encourage him to emphasize what
he was told rather than any
ideas he might have.
You would get substantially
better Okun lectures,
I suspect, as a consequence,
if the feedback that I got is
any guide.
I want to thank everybody for
their hospitality and having
seen a certain number of these
kinds of lecture series over
time.
When I was President of
Harvard, my deepest nightmare,
one of my deepest
nightmares--some of my
nightmares actually came
true--but some of my lesser
nightmares as President of
Harvard were the sequential
lecture series,
where at the third lecture no
one came.
As a lecturer,
I was concerned the judgment of
those who had seen the product
is of more interest than the
judgment of those who have not.
So, the fact that the room
looks a little bit like the room
looked yesterday,
I take as at least mild
encouragement and validation to
proceed.
Yesterday, I talked about two
types of recessions.
What I referred to as
disinflation recessions,
in which the Fed stepped on the
brakes,
the economy slowed,
the Feds stepped off the
brakes, the economy
reaccelerated.
And, what was my larger focus,
financial system breakdown
recessions, in which in one way
or another,
bubbles burst or banks face
liquidity problems or the supply
of finance dried up and the
economy suffered.
I suggested that the latter
category of recession was the
historical pattern of recession.
That there were some signs that
the more relevant problem for
the United States going forward
might well be the latter kind of
recession as well.
I implied a thought I will
develop in the course of these
remarks--that the incipient
recession in the United States
is almost certainly of the
latter financial breakdown
variety rather than the
disinflation variety.
We have had instructive,
for me, conversations at both
dinner and lunch on the question
of how one thinks about these
two categories of recession in
the context of an ISLM model or
in the context of a simple--some
kind of simple--macroeconomic
model.
The correct answer to that
question, I think,
is that it's pretty unambiguous
that a disinflation recession is
best thought of as the Federal
Reserve tightening money,
which represents some kind of
leftward movement of the LM
curve--that output declines and
interest rates rise and that
that's the proximate shock that
is bringing about the recession.
That it turns out to be a
matter of semantic
ambiguity--how to think about a
financial crisis recession in
the context of a simple
macroeconomic model.
Everybody agrees on the
movement of three variables in
such a recession.
Output goes down;
q goes down;
and short-term interest rates
go down.
One instinct,
which is probably not the first
instinct in the City of New
Haven,
is to think of that recession
in a traditional ISLM curve,
with the IS curve and the LM
curve being plotted in a space
determined by the level of
output and the short term
interest rate.
In that formulation,
it is clearly an IS shock.
The level of output declines;
the level of interest rates
decline as well.
An alternative formulation and
a formulation that is probably
more in the spirit of Yale
economics is to think of the
ISLM diagram as having been
drawn in a space that focuses on
output and the required return
to capital or focuses on output
and q.
In a formulation of that kind,
there hasn't been a shock to
the relationship between
investment and the price of
capital.
There's been a shock to the
price of capital at any given
level of the short-term interest
rate.
And so, one thinks of it as
part of the dynamics of the LM
curve.
However one views that question
of the IS curve versus the LM
curve, the operative distinction
between the two kinds of shocks
is that in a disinflation shock,
interest rates are up and that
is why output is down.
In a financial breakdown shock,
output is down and that is why
policy interest rates or safe
interest rates are reduced.
From that perspective,
it's very clear what the
current episode is.
As expectations of future
output have declined,
as asset prices have declined,
one is seeing very substantial
declines in Treasury bond yields
and in the Federal Funds Rate.
For those who are aficionados
of such things,
I will mention that for a
period of a week,
the five-year TIPS yield was
significantly--it was
negative--at one point reaching
negative twenty-two basis
points.
There was a brief three-hour
period in Japan when the
one-month Treasury Bill was
yielding not two basis points,
not one basis point,
but literally zero basis points
as a consequence of various
machinations in the money market
that had the character of an
extreme flight to safety.
If one thinks about the
duration and the policy response
to recessions of these two
kinds, they are usefully
distinguished.
The policy response and the
dynamics of disinflation
recessions are not profoundly
complicated.
The Fed steps on the brakes;
depending on how hard the Fed
steps on the brakes,
the recession's duration is
uncertain.
At a certain point,
when it is satisfied that
sufficient disinflation has
taken place or when it feels
that other imperatives take
precedence,
the Fed removes its foot from
the brakes, allows short-term
interest rates to decline,
and eventually the economy
expands.
There's no great mystery about
it.
The length and depth of the
recession is closely tied to the
strength, force,
and length of the Fed
tightening and the speed with
which it eases.
Hence, there was much more
disinflation to be done in
1980-82 and the recession
interest rates were pushed up
much further;
the recession was that much
more severe.
The matter is much more complex
when one turns to financial
overextension recessions.
Thinking about the limited
sample of data,
it falls into two broad
categories.
The first is the recessions
that didn't happen or happened
only barely.
There was a pretty exciting
financial crisis in 1987 and
nothing really happened.
There was a pretty exciting
financial crisis for those
involved in 1998.
In neither case,
if I gave you the data on
unemployment,
GNP, consumption,
any real variable and I didn't
give you the time scale and I
said--What year did we have a
20% stock market crash?
What year did we have a really
dramatic set of dislocations in
financial markets as a major
hedge fund failed?
You wouldn't be able to see it.
Even the 2001 recession,
which was associated with the
bursting of the NASDAQ bubble,
is a pretty minimal recession.
In retrospect,
with the data revised,
there is no two-quarter period
when GDP declined.
There are two quarters in which
GDP declined,
but they're separated by a
quarter of modest positive
growth.
It is not the case that all
financial crises,
or even most financial crises,
lead to economic downturns.
Some have a natural explanation
of that.
Essentially,
they explain that the financial
sector is only one small part of
the economy--that the decline in
the financial sector of the
economy is not of that much
consequence.
With reasonable policy
responses, either with monetary
policy or with fiscal policy,
and automatic stabilizers any
loss in demand can be offset.
Not a typical calculation of
this kind would say,
suppose the stock market lost
20% of its value.
If the value of the stock
market is on the order of the
value of GNP,
that's a loss of 20% of GNP.
If the marginal propensity to
consume out of wealth is 4%,
the loss is 8/10% of GNP--an
amount that an economy would
rather not lose,
but hardly the difference
between economic success and
economic failure and something
that's potentially offset if
there is some policy response.
There is data and evidence for
the view that a significant
amount of financial disruption
can take place with relatively
little consequence for the real
economy.
The difficulty is that there
are other data points as well as
1987 and 1998 and 2001.
There are data points that come
from the United States in the
aftermath of 1929,
while those,
perhaps, are in so different in
institutional environment,
with such egregious errors as
to not be relevant.
There are data points from
Japan during the 1990s.
There are any number of data
points from emerging markets in
which the reality of financial
problems created very large
losses in output.
It's natural to ask,
why is the response to
financial crises so
heterogeneous with some episodes
in which they seem to have very
little consequence and some
episodes in which they seem to
have so very much?
I think the natural
explanation, though it's
difficult to prove in any kind
of conclusive way,
is an idea that runs through
the work of many economists and
probably in recent decades most
strongly through Ben Bernanke's
work,
suggesting that financial
intermediation capital is a
substantial contributor to the
production process.
When it is destroyed,
suddenly there are substantial
losses, both to aggregate supply
and to aggregate demand.
I made this point--tried to
make this point--graphic in a
conversation with one of your
colleagues by asking the
question,
suppose one considered the
following macroeconomic shock.
For the next six months,
it will not be possible to make
and complete a phone call in the
United States.
What would be likely to happen
to the GDP of the United States
and what would be likely to
happen to the performance of the
American economy?
It's actually sort of an
interesting question and I don't
have a clue exactly what the
right answer is.
My strong suspicion is that it
would really be quite a bad
event for the performance of the
economy.
The question of whether the
telephone lines would transmit
bits would obviously be very
important in--or it would only
stop working for the human
voice--would be a very important
determinant.
In either case,
it's hard to believe that there
would not be substantial loss of
output and significant loss of
employment as well.
There would be many methods for
seeking to estimate the value of
the losses,
but I would argue that a
particularly poor method would
be to ask, what's the market
value of all the telephone
companies?
Let's say the market value of
all the telephone companies is a
trillion dollars.
If they're not going to earn
anything for a year,
then their market value will go
down by $400 billion dollars.
So, we'll multiply $400 billion
dollars by a marginal propensity
to demand--marginal propensity
to consume--and we'll add
something for the fact--and
we'll call that lost demand.
We'll say, there needs to be
some increased demand because we
need to fix the telephones;
so, that'll be some increased
investment.
That would, it seems to me,
be the wrong mode of analysis.
In some way,
one would want to capture the
idea that the production
potential of the economy would
be lower because the
opportunities to generate output
out of a given amount of capital
and a given amount of labor
would be impossible without the
intercommunication that the
telephone makes possible.
The results,
I would suggest,
of that telephone shock would
be lost output and would also be
lost output without substantial
disinflation benefit because the
lost output would not come in a
way that created lots of goods
hanging over markets that led to
declines in prices.
The benefit,
in terms of disinflation,
of a downturn induced by the
inability to make a phone call
would be much less than the
benefit of a similar loss of
output achieved through the more
standard tools of fiscal and
monetary policy.
I emphasize this last point
because it connects with the
observation with which I began
yesterday--that declines in
output associated with financial
crisis recession,
if avoidable,
probably create a welfare gain
of the kind that Art Okun
focused so much on and of the
kind that Jim Tobin emphasized
when he spoke of all those
Harberger triangles filling an
Okun gap.
And [they]
are not susceptible to the
critique that what you lose on
the swings you gain on the
swerves that's associated with
the more conventional view of
cyclical fluctuations.
It should be clear,
from what I have said,
where I am going.
My suggestion is really,
to echo Ben Bernanke's
suggestion, that the destruction
of financial intermediation
capital should be thought of as
reducing the economy's potential
to generate output and,
in that process,
making people poorer and
reducing the level of demand as
well.
When that process kicks in to a
substantial extent--that,
I would suggest,
is the occasion on which
financial crises prove to be
exciting events outside of the
precincts of Manhattan and
Chicago.
The crucial question for
economic policy in responding to
these crises,
I would suggest,
is preventing that kind of
destruction of intermediation
capital from taking place on a
large scale.
That brings me to the policy
task that the U.S.
authorities face at the current
moment.
I'd like to define the problem
as managing and containing three
separate vicious cycle
mechanisms.
The first is the one that I
spoke about at length
yesterday--what one might call
the liquidation cycle.
The tendency,
more than a tendency,
in the market for fixed-income
instruments,
particularly mortgage-backed
securities, to some degree in
the market for housing for
declines in value to give rise
to selling pressures that create
further declines in value
reinforcing the vicious cycle.
The second vicious cycle,
which builds on that,
is what is traditionally
referred to as the
credit-accelerator cycle.
A deteriorating financial
economy leads to less lending;
leads to a deteriorating real
economy;
leads to less capacity to pay
back debt;
leads to declining values of
financial instruments;
leads to further reductions in
lending and the cycle continues.
The third cycle--the third
potentially destabilizing
mechanism is the one that's
perhaps most familiar--the
Keynesian mechanism in which
reduced spending leads to
reduced income leads to reduced
spending and on.
Containing these mutually
reinforcing cycles is,
I would suggest now,
the central challenge for
economic policy.
I am not in a position to make
authoritative estimates of some
of the relevant magnitudes and I
don't want my estimates to be
given more seriousness than
their crudity deserves,
which is why I'm not projecting
them on a screen.
Let me give you some round
numbers that are quite close to
the judgment of the various
investment banks and informed
observers who have studied these
questions.
The equity capital of leveraged
financial institutions in the
United States totals about two
trillion dollars.
It totaled a little more than
two trillion dollars a few
months ago;
it probably totals a little
less than two trillion dollars
today.
That two trillion dollars of
capital supported about twenty
trillion dollars of asset
holding.
In other words,
those institutions were levered
ten-to-one;
some were levered much more
than ten-to-one.
Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac are,
for example,
levered thirty-to-one.
A bank with an 8% capital
requirement is levered
twelve-to-one;
others--hedge funds pursuing
certain strategies--are levered
considerably less than
ten-to-one.
On average, the leverage works
out to about ten-to-one--two
trillion dollars of equity
capital, twenty trillion dollars
of lending.
The losses that have taken
place over the last nine months
and the projected losses based
on reasonable models of
fundamentals--these are not
marked-to-market losses that
build in what might be market
overreactions.
These are estimates of what
will happen to mortgage
securities based on assumptions
that,
for example,
house prices will decline by
another 15% from current levels.
Estimates of those total losses
are about a trillion dollars.
That trillion-dollar figure
sounds very scary,
relative to two trillion
dollars of capital in the
intermediation sector.
But, good news--about half
those losses are outside the
financial intermediary sector.
They're Bill Brainard's pension;
they're the State of Nebraska's
pension fund;
they're the Yale endowment;
they're life insurance
companies, and the like.
So, about half are held by
levered intermediaries.
And more good news--the levered
intermediaries are mostly,
sooner or later,
in one way or another,
going to get tax deductions of
various kinds.
When all is said and done,
the losses of capital to the
intermediation sector represent
about $300 billion dollars.
$300 billion dollars of lost
capital has been offset so far
by about $150 billion dollars of
capital that has been raised in
Citigroup's deal with Abu Dhabi
and the like.
Lost capital,
which can be estimated with
some degree of accuracy compared
to the next step in this
calculation,
represents about $150 billion
dollars.
$150 billion dollars of lost
capital at ten-to-one leverage
means a trillion and a half
dollars of lost intermediation
capacity or about 7.5% of the
financial asset holding that was
previously taking place.
Now, here comes a wild card;
what should happen to the
leverage of intermediaries in
the face of the events of the
last nine months?
Well, first of all,
they probably should have
learned from the last nine
months that the degree of
leverage with which they were
operating nine months ago was
excessive.
Second, they almost certainly
will judge that the volatility
associated with the assets they
hold and the degree of
uncertainty about their
portfolios is today very
substantially greater,
not just than they thought it
was nine months ago,
but than it objectively was
nine months ago.
Third, the magnitude of tail
risk of existential events,
which will cause the solvency
of their institution to come
into fundamental doubt,
has surely increased as well.
I don't think we have a sound
basis for estimating how much
prudent institutions will reduce
their leverage.
The leverage choices they may
make will, of course,
be very much influenced,
in some cases,
by the way in which the
government applies capital
rules.
If one makes the conservative,
but in my view not absurd,
assumption that leverage will
be reduced by 10%,
10% leverage--a 10% reduction
in leverage on a $20 trillion
base of asset holding represents
the loss of another $2 trillion
in lending capacity.
Add the $1.5 trillion and the
$2 trillion and you are looking
at the loss of,
on the order of,
$3.5 trillion or on the order
of 15% of the previous financial
intermediation capacity.
It is not unreasonable at all
to suppose that this is a shock
that is of substantial magnitude
relative to the functioning of
the financial system and to the
extent that the economy is
dependent on the ability to get
credit to the functioning of the
economy.
At root, it is the challenge of
policy to address this shock in
this environment.
What are the tools that are
available to policymakers?
The first imperative of a
policy and one that has been
pursued in this crisis since the
beginning of 2008,
albeit in my judgment somewhat
belatedly, is to seek to
maintain aggregate demand.
Whatever else is happening,
an environment of this kind is
likely to be a disinflationary
environment over time.
It is likely to be an
environment in which if spending
is reduced, asset values will
decline, further compounding the
degree of economic damage.
How do policymakers seek to
maintain aggregate demand?
Before the events of the last
eighteen months,
if asked to comment on this
subject,
I would have said the dominant
tool of short-run stabilization
policy should be monetary policy
not fiscal policy.
I would have explained that
fiscal policy,
except in the shortest of runs,
was likely to be offset by the
Federal Reserve.
So, it would end up affecting
the composition of output,
not the level of output.
I would further have explained
that it was much more
destructive of long-run values
to try to vary spending or the
tax structure in a short-run way
in order to stabilize the
economy;
that was best accomplished
through monetary policy.
I continue to regard that as a
reasonable judgment about policy
in normal times.
It seems to me that,
while it is appropriate in this
environment to seek to use
monetary policy as a tool of
stimulus,
there are several
considerations that suggest that
it should not be the sole tool
of stimulus in this environment.
First, there is much more than
the normal degree of uncertainty
about what the impact of changes
in interest rates will be on the
level of aggregate demand.
Imagine, for example,
an intermediary that is
capital-constrained.
It only has a billion dollars
of capital and it therefore can
only lend ten billion dollars.
Imagine now that the rate of
interest is brought down;
it can still only lend ten
billion dollars and the rate at
which it lends will still be the
point at which the demand curve
for its loans is at ten billion
dollars.
The only result of bringing
down the interest rate will be a
reduction in its cost of
funding,
which over time will allow it
to rebuild its capital,
but that is a very slow
process--a very different
situation than the more normal
situation in which the
intermediary is not constrained.
Is this the case for most
intermediaries?
It's very difficult to know.
Most intermediaries are not at
their capital constraint,
but they probably are planning
for some given cushion relative
to their capital constraint.
In this environment,
it is likely that the
multiplier for monetary policy
is less and it is surely more
uncertain and that is an
inhibition to the use of
monetary policy.
Second inhibition to the use of
monetary policy as a sole tool
is: most of the time,
with respect to most economic
policies, we may not know what
the multiplier associated with
the instrument is,
but we know where we have set
the policy dial.
Through all of modern economic
experience, until nine months
ago, it would be completely
impossible to use any known
econometric technique to say
anything about the impact of
changes in the Fed Funds Rate,
as distinct from changes in
LIBOR, on the behavior of the
aggregate economy.
They were perfectly
multi-linear as the spread
between them was small and
little fluctuating.
In the last nine months,
a substantial spread has
emerged between the Fed Funds
Rate--the rate at which banks
lend to each other
overnight--and the Interbank
rate that prevails over longer
horizons.
For a variety of reasons that I
don't have time to get into,
it is almost certainly the case
that large parts of this spread
reflect the credit risk that
banks experience when they lend
to each other.
Probably, the right indicator
for monetary policy is not the
Fed Funds Rate,
but is LIBOR,
in which case there has been
rather less easing of monetary
policy than looking at the Fed
Funds Rate would suggest;
but, one cannot make that
decision in a definitive way.
So, easing monetary policy as
the Fed has been doing for some
time and as the Fed did today in
lowering the rate another
twenty-five basis points is
almost certainly appropriate.
But it is almost certainly not
appropriate to rely only on a
single instrument in this
context because one is uncertain
about how much of that
instrument one is applying,
because one is uncertain about
what the multiplier of that
instrument is,
and because in the current
context there are reasons to be
concerned about the pernicious
side effects of excessively low
interest rates.
Two stand out.
The first--while in general I
am very much with the Keynesian
consensus that the inflation
process depends upon aggregate
demand,
in the current context,
lower interest rates may well
contribute directly to the
inflation process through their
impact on the dollar and through
their impact on commodity
prices.
The second--while I give less
weight than most to critiques of
a policy environment that blame
our current problems on the fact
that interest rates were kept
low for a long time responding
to the last recession,
it seems to me reasonable to
give some weight to the concern
that excessively low interest
rates set the stage for future
bubbles.
I, therefore,
think it's appropriate that the
Congress acted--and I suspect
the Congress won't need to act
again--to provide fiscal
stimulus to the economy.
In advocating fiscal stimulus
just after the turn of the year,
I urged that the stimulus be
timely because experience
suggests that the difficulty of
lags and implementation have
traditionally been serious with
respect to fiscal policy.
That it be targeted--designed
to generate as much spending as
possible as quickly as possible,
which meant that tax breaks
should be channeled to those
with lower incomes rather than
those with higher incomes.
That recommendation if adopted;
means that taxes--means that
benefit programs would go to
people like food stamps and
unemployment insurance
recipients,
who were likely to have a very
high-margin propensity to
consume.
The political process was
unwilling to do that.
And that the fiscal stimulus
must be temporary in light of
the seriousness of the country's
long-run fiscal problems.
Macroeconomic policy in this
environment can help to maintain
aggregate demand,
but it does not address the
disruption in the productive
mechanism associated with the
decline in the financial sectors
capacity for intermediation.
There are a number of tools of
policy directed at the
maintenance of financial
stability.
One has received overwhelming
emphasis to date and it is
entirely appropriate,
but I would suggest
presumptively insufficient.
That is, the Fed,
through a dizzying array of new
facilities and ad hoc actions,
has made clear that it stands
ready against good collateral to
provide liquidity to financial
institutions.
Now, go back to the
calculations that I went through
a moment ago.
I emphasized the loss of
capital and I represented the
desired reduction in levels of
leverage associated with a more
risky environment.
I did not say anything in doing
those calculations about the
difficulty of attracting funds,
about the difficulty of
borrowing funds.
I did not raise the concern
about bank runs and the like.
The provision of liquidity by
the Fed is necessary;
without it, in my judgment,
it is very likely that we would
have seen problematic runs on a
number of institutions.
I believe the Fed behaved in a
broadly correct way in
responding to the events at Bear
Stearns.
It is certainly possible that
if the Fed had not acted,
the losses to Bear Stearns
shareholders would have been
total.
There would have been
substantial disruption in the
bond markets for a period of
five days.
A valuable lesson would have
been taught and the matter--and
the world would have moved
forward.
It is certainly possible that
that is the case.
It seems to me,
one doesn't need to assign a
very high probability to the
alternative scenario in which
runs on Bear Stearns cascaded to
other institutions,
which then cascaded to other
institutions and led to
substantial destruction of many
institutions that were thought
previously viable.
I don't think one has to assign
a very great probability to the
latter event to believe the
rescue of Bear Stearns was
worthwhile.
I, myself, would assign a much
greater than 50% probability to
a major systemic-risk incident
if the damage at Bear Stearns
had not been contained.
In any event,
while noting the necessity of
all of that, I want to emphasize
its insufficiency--that it does
nothing about either the
reduction in capital and it does
very little about the reduction
in desired degrees of leverage,
that I would suggest are at the
root of the problem.
That brings me to what is,
I think, the second crucial
tool of financial stability,
which is the most important
financial policy issue in the
current environment.
Unfortunately,
by its nature,
it is difficult to tell the
vigor with which it is being
pursued.
That is the infusion of new
capital into financial
institutions.
Notice that if financial
institutions raised their level
capital, then at any given level
of leverage they are able to
raise their degree of lending
and you are able to reinstitute
the intermediation capacity that
has been lost.
There is a crucial
un-internalized externality in
our current system of financial
regulation.
Institutions are regulated and
their soundness is judged on the
basis of a capital ratio--on the
basis of their degree of
leverage.
They are pressured rationally
enough not to have deposits that
are short-term liabilities that
are too large relative to their
degree of capital.
Notice that an institution can
acquire--can reduce its--can
improve its capital ratio or
reduce its leverage in one of
two ways.
It can reduce its leverage by
shrinking its balance sheet or
it can reduce its leverage by
expanding its level of capital.
If the institution is
indifferent between those two
choices, society is clearly not
choices.
It has a strong preference for
the issuance of capital.
Or to put essentially the same
point in a different way,
if an institution raises
capital,
it dilutes its shareholders and
a substantial part of the
benefit of that extra capital
goes to the holders of its risky
debt,
whose claims have now become
more secure.
As a consequence,
the private incentive for
capital raising,
even with a capital rule
operating as regulation,
is substantially less than the
social incentive.
One hopes that the regulatory
system is internalizing this
externality--is placing
substantial pressure on
institutions,
who after all are enormously
dependent on their relationship
with the financial authorities
to raise more capital than they
otherwise would.
It is very difficult to know
from the outside to what extent
that is taking place.
A prudent regulator who was
forcing an institution to raise
more capital would conspire with
that institution to not have it
be known that the regulator was
forcing the institution to raise
more capital,
lest the health of the
institution come into question.
Certainly there have been a
number of favorable developments
involving the raising of capital
in recent months,
but in my judgment and the kind
of numbers I presented suggest
that we have a long way to go.
I would suggest,
of particular importance in
this regard is the capital
situation of the
government-sponsored
enterprises,
which are levered thirty-to-one
and which have a crucial role in
this environment in supporting
the mortgage market.
To date, they have been
encouraged to buy more mortgages
through a reduction in their
capital requirement and there
have been rather diffuse
statements about it as their
hope and intention to raise more
capital in the future.
We've been moving towards the
future;
they have not yet raised the
capital.
Some rather skeptical
statements about the need to
raise capital have come from
their management with as yet
relatively little criticism from
the public
authorities--liquidity,
raising capital.
The third broad policy question
involves more direct
intervention in markets.
In my judgment,
any attempt to support the
housing market,
in general, at current levels
would be misguided.
There is little reason to
believe that house prices have
yet fallen to fundamental
levels, let alone fallen through
fundamental levels.
The lesson of the Japanese
experience is that price keeping
operations by governments delay
processes of adjustment.
Why would anyone want to buy
something whose price is being
supported by the government
since it's likely that there
will be further downwards
adjustment rather than upwards
adjustment?
Where there is a much stronger
case is for policy to support
the mortgage-backed security
market where prices reflect
expectations of terribly high
default performances.
Some mortgage-backed securities
on some classes of subprime debt
are building in the expectation
that more than half the houses
will be foreclosed;
estimates that go way beyond
what even fairly pessimistic
forecasts suggest.
By stealth, a rather
substantial program of support
for the mortgage-backed
securities market is under way.
Key elements include the
actions of the
government-sponsored enterprises
that I referred to that will
enable $180 billion of increased
purchasing of mortgage-backed
securities.
A similar change on the part of
the federal home loan banks and
if, with that thirty-to-one
leverage ratio,
the GSE's are caused to raise
significantly more capital,
there is the prospect of
significantly further support
for the mortgage-backed
securities market,
whose greater health would
impact both the availability of
credit to potential new
homeowners and the
availability--and the health--of
the financial institutions that
are holding their securities.
I think--and I will not dwell
on the point for reasons of
time--that there is also a
strong case for policy measures
directed at strategic
intervention in near foreclosure
situations to promote the
writing down of mortgages as an
alternative to foreclosure.
Given that, available estimates
suggest that the losses
associated with the foreclosure
process itself can easily add up
to more than half the value--the
residual value--of the home.
Finally, I would highlight the
international dimension of
policy and would stress two
aspects.
The global dynamic here is that
two things are happening.
First, U.S.
aggregate demand is falling.
Second, the fall in the dollar
associated with all the various
ramifications of these financial
events are switching expenditure
from the rest of the world
towards the United States.
Third, some of the forces
operating in the United States
are also operating to reduce
aggregate demand in the rest of
the world.
A crucial priority for policy
coordination in that context has
to be the stimulation of
aggregate demand in the rest of
the world and,
probably, the achievement of a
more balanced pattern of dollar
depreciation.
To date, the dollar has
depreciated disproportionately
against a very small number of
currencies,
principally the Euro,
that stand for countries that
do not have problems like those
of the United States and that
allow their exchange rate to
fluctuate;
a more balanced path would be
desirable.
Second priority for policy
coordination is with respect to
the very large quantities of
liquidity that are now managed
by governments.
They represent,
potentially,
an enormously important
resource in the current
context--pools of patient
capital that can be managed for
the long term and that could
provide liquidity to badly
distorted fixed-income markets,
but have not yet done so on a
substantial scale.
These sets of measures
represent, I believe,
a policy approach that offers a
very good,
though not certain,
chance of containing the
current situation.
The risks, it seems to me,
are much more on the side of it
being pursued with too little
vigor than on the side of it
being pursued with too much.
In particular,
the imperative of the rapid
recapitalization of financial
institutions stands out.
I will for reasons of time
leave a discussion that I had
intended, raising questions
about the regulatory structure
and changes that might make
crises of these kind less likely
in the future,
to the question period.
But, I will just make five
telegraphic observations.
First, it is the irony of
financial crisis that the very
forces that caused it are the
opposite--are also the very
forces that are necessary to get
out of it.
If the world's problem eighteen
months ago was that there was
too much greed and too little
fear,
the world's problem today is
that there is too much fear and
too little greed.
The policies that would have
been highly constructive
eighteen months ago in
inhibiting undesirable lending
are potentially
counterproductive today in
inhibiting constructive lending.
Second, there's an overwhelming
case for stronger consumer
regulation in all financial
areas.
If one studies carefully the
extent to which subprime
mortgages at egregious interest
rates were taken on to help
people get out of credit card
debt at super egregious rates,
one has a sense of the greater
complexity of the problem and
the need to view it from an
integrated consumer perspective.
Third, the government should be
paid for providing the safety
net and the modalities that are
necessary to do that--need to be
much more carefully designed so
that if everything works out
splendidly in,
for example,
the Bear Stearns transaction,
the government would be a
beneficiary of the success since
it surely will be a
beneficiary--surely will bear
the burden if everything else is
lost.
Fourth, the dominant--the
single most important area for
thought in thinking about the
future of financial regulation
is the problem of
pro-cyclicality.
Prudent behavior by individual
institutions involves shrinkage
of balance sheets in bad times.
Everyone's effort to shrink
balance sheets in bad times has
potentially catastrophic
consequences for the system.
How to regulate to avoid
pro-cyclicality is a fourth
crucial imperative.
Fifth, these issues should be
addressed slowly,
carefully, and deliberately;
as I suggested,
the problems of getting us out
of a situation of this kind are
in many ways the opposite of the
problems of preventing future
financial crises.
It will be tempting,
but would be unfortunate,
to address the concerns through
whatever officials do when
they're not sure what to do,
which is reorganize.
Our central challenges involve
the questions of how we define
capital, how we regulate
capital,
for whom we regulate capital,
how we avoid pro-cyclicality.
Until we know the answers to
those questions,
it will be difficult to think
intelligently about what the
right bureaucratic structure of
regulation is.
All of this is to suggest to
the students here that the
macroeconomics of the early
twenty-first century will be no
less important than the
macroeconomics of the latter
part of the twentieth century.
That macroeconomics has a good
chance of being much more
centrally involved with
financial issues than the
macroeconomics of the late
twentieth century--or perhaps
fairness requires me to say,
the macroeconomics practiced
outside of New Haven in the late
twentieth century.
The many, many imprecisions and
speculations in these remarks,
I apologize for,
but offer as a modest and
inadequate defense that they
point up that there's a great
deal of very valuable research
to be done that will contribute
to our understanding of
economies.
Also, I believe,
to Art Okun's vision,
of harnessing that
understanding to help make
better and more secure lives for
our fellow citizens.
Thank you very much.
I went over my time,
but I've got some time for
questions.
Jeff?
Student: Larry,
do you think that Secretary
Paulson's recommendations are
appropriate to the problem?
Or do they that seem to be a
dusted off failed answer to a
different set of problems.
Secretary Paulson's
recommendations last year
addressed a presumed crisis
overregulation diminishing.
You seem to suggest that the
real problems are misperceptions
of risk and not mistaken
regulation.
Will the Secretary's repurposed
proposals die on the vine or
will they still get political
traction despite your warning?
Sorry about the mixed metaphor!
Professor Larry Summers:
Get traction on the vine,
I guess.
There's certain--I'm going to
not associate myself with all
the words you used in describing
the Secretary's proposals,
though I can't understand
why--I can understand why you
use them.
I think that it is almost
always a good idea to bet on
inertia in anything political.
I suspect that in the remainder
of this election year it is very
unlikely that anything will get
done that doesn't appear
necessary to respond to current
difficulty.
And usually,
when there's a new
administration or a new
secretary, the problem is not
excessive fealty to the visions
of the previous secretary,
the problem is a desperate
effort at artificial product
differentiation.
There were a number of issues I
found when I was at the Treasury
where there was a certain way to
do it that was kind of a good
idea and,
actually, our predecessors had
more or less figured it out.
It was my experience that we
never decided to say,
let's really work to get
Secretary Brady's good idea in
place.
We always found a few points of
minor difference and found a
variety of ways of relabeling
it.
That was when we thought the
ideas were good and he had it
right.
In the cases where we didn't,
it was much more dramatic.
So, I would be surprised if the
ideas contained in that report
prove to be a dominant starting
point for discussion.
To be sure, I do want to say
one thing.
There is one thing that that
report was getting at and there
is one aspect of our system that
I think we need to think very
carefully about and it goes
deep.
That is, do we believe in
competitive regulation of
financial institutions?
We have a banking system and it
has for a long time been a
fairly sacred principle that we
have a so-called "dual banking
system."
The idea is,
well you get to choose your
regulator and therefore no
regulator can be too stupid
because if they're unreasonable
or stupid,
then people will choose a
different regulator.
Well, that's one way of
thinking about it.
Another is that if regulators
like to have more jurisdiction
and they like to do more stuff,
competitive regulation is a
prescription for limited
regulation.
Implicit in Secretary
Paulson's--sort of,
in the language one might
expect from a Republican,
emphasis on efficiency and the
avoidance of duplication was a
moving away from competitive
regulation.
I suspect that maybe quite an
important idea.
T,N?
Student: It is all very
well to say in a general way
that it is good to avoid
duplication and to move away
from competitive regulation
without going to where the
trade-off lies in different
contexts.
After all there is a lot of
experience to draw upon.
For example U.S.,
India, the E.U.
and many others have more than
one regulaory authority for
different parts of the financial
sector sector while the U.K.
has just one.
All the time the sector itself
expanding with new agents,
poroducts etc entering all the
time, in part as a response to
the system in place.
Based on your experience and
analytical skills where do you
come out on this issue?
Professor Larry Summers:
The question said--I'm going to
rephrase the question.
The question was,
okay Larry that's good,
but don't duck all the
interesting questions.
There's a lot of experience in
a lot of places.
In particular,
England has a single financial
regulator.
If you had to guess right now,
what's the best way to do it?
Is that a fair rephrase of the
question, T.N.?
I think that the three things I
would emphasize are:
competitive regulation is
probably a mistake if you
believe in regulation.
The central bank does need to
have a role in financial
regulation of major institutions
because if it doesn't have a
role in the regulation of
financial institutions,
it's not going to know things
that it should know and it's
going to end up living with the
consequences.
So, the central bank should be
crucially involved in the
regulation of major financial
institutions.
That--it's a--if you believe in
regulations that are pursuing
objectives that are not
immediately in the interest of
financial institutions--If you
believe in those
regulations--consumer
regulations,
community regulations and the
like--If you believe in those
regulations and you want them
carried out with vigor,
you need to give them to their
own regulator,
who is not responsible for the
health of the institutions in
the way that the Federal Reserve
is.
Separation of consumer
regulation, elimination of
competitive regulation,
and regulation of major
financial institutions by an
entity--by a single entity--in
which the central bank has a
role would be the three
principles that I would suggest.
John?
Student: I would like to
make a comment and ask two
questions.
My comment is,
like everyone I'm sure,
we all enjoyed your talk very
much.
Professor Larry Summers:
The comment is he enjoyed the
talk.
That tends to--that's the kind
of thing you say before the
devastating question and I knew
John when we were in graduate
school together and nothing in
my four years of going to
graduate school with him makes
it less likely that after he
said,
he really enjoyed the talk,
that the devastating question
was going to come.
So I am braced.
Student: It took me five
years of graduate school.
But anyway, your story of the
leverage cycle,
as I called it,
where people leveraged too much
in good times and then in bad
times just when you want them to
leverage,
the leverage drops in the
system and there's not
enough--there's too little
leverage to get you out of the
doldrums.
I think it's a very important
story.
So, that was my comment,
but the question though is--
Professor Larry Summers:
I thought at least I got the
comment,
which was that he really liked
the talk;
that didn't even count at all.
Okay go right ahead.
Student: The question
is, you don't seem to have
follow through to the end of the
story,
which is that if you think that
the leverage is not being set by
supply and demand properly--too
much in good times and not
enough in bad times--then I
would have thought--maybe you're
saving this for the question
period,
so I'm giving you a chance to
say it--then you would think
that regulators ought to
intervene to change the
leverage.
So for example,
in good times they can prevent
people from leveraging so much
and in bad times--it's a little
more difficult to see what you
can do,
but particularly what I want
you to talk about--how can the
Fed intervene in a way to
increase the leverage?
For example,
should it directly lend against
collateral.
But, they'll lend more money
against collateral than the
market is willing to do,
not lend at lower interest
rates.
But, just staying on your
mortgage derivative,
which the market will only lend
$50 on,
the Fed will take that as
collateral, lend it the same
interest rate the market will,
but lend $60 on it instead of
$50.
Do you think the Fed should do
that and if it has been doing
that?
That's the first question.
The second question is,
you talked about the housing
crisis and there's 50% of houses
and people may be [Inaudible]
subprime borrowers--that's 2.5
million of them that have been
tossed out of their houses.
You said at the same time that
you think innovation sometimes
prolongs a problem and makes it
worse.
But getting rid of this $180
billion that you spoke of is not
going to make much of a dent in
2.5 million families being
tossed out of their houses.
So, do you think there should
be some more,
bigger intervention?
One that I would suggest is the
people doing the lending are the
ones who are going to lose all
the money when these people are
thrown out of their houses.
They're the ones with the
biggest interest to seeing
something done.
They're paralyzed because the
bondholders are split up so
completely that they can't
coordinate.
They're remodifying the terms
of the loan and no single banker
would let 2.5 million families
be thrown out on the streets and
have their houses sold for 50%
of the loan.
Can you think of a way of
coordinating these people--these
lenders--who are uncoordinated,
so that they themselves,
without the government having
to put up any money,
can help solve the problem?
Professor Larry Summers:
There are two characteristically
good questions.
On the first question,
which was about pro-cyclical
leverage--as I tried to explain,
I'm not sure the focus on
leverage is right rather than
the focus being on lending.
Those are quite different
things.
I actually think that the world
is more risky;
the uncertainty surrounding
what's going to happen to loans
is greater than it was a
year--certainly than people
perceived it to be a year and a
half ago.
So, I'm not sure institutions
should have much higher leverage
today than they did a year and a
half ago.
That's why I put emphasis on
what I think is the right thing.
I'm not sure they should have
more leverage;
they should have more lending
and there's a way of getting to
more lending without having more
leverage, which is raising more
capital.
That's why I emphasized the
importance of pressuring
institutions to raise more
capital and that's why,
without having any terribly
compelling way to concretize it,
I think in our thinking about
regulation we need to get a bit
away from the capital ratio as
the central variable since what
we want is capital raising now,
not balance sheet shrinking.
An emphasis on the capital
ratio treats those two as
equivalent when they're not in
fact equivalent.
The one suggestion that has
been made, and I have no idea
whether it actually works out in
a viable way,
is to force institutions to
issue some kind of security that
is a reverse convertible that
becomes--that converts from debt
to equity in difficult times.
It's hard to see why that
security is going to feel a lot
like debt when you buy it in the
good times,
so I'm not sure whether that
works out, but that's the type
of thing that one has to think
about.
I would resist the idea of
framing the question through the
leverage ratio.
Should the government try in
good times to require levels of
capital or limits on leverage
that go beyond what appears to
be prudential for individual
institutions in the name of
protection of the system?
I'm probably one big financial
mess away from being in favor of
that.
Not quite there because I think
you've got to be very careful
about the adverse effects if you
don't do it very carefully.
Once you're talking about a
punitive capital requirement
that's not related to your
institution's prudential needs,
the incentive to avoid it is
very strong.
So, if you don't do it for
every institution,
the action is going to migrate
away and if you do do it for
every institution,
you're getting to a pretty
dirigiste place,
in which the government is
regulating in a lot of places
where it's probably not going to
be so good at regulating.
Your other question was about
the foreclosure and mortgage
problem.
I think one of the easiest
judgments to make,
in the sense that there's a
measure available that has a
reasonable chance of doing good
and has,
I think, roughly no chance of
doing bad, is the legislation
that's been introduced by
Senator McCaskill and others to
remove legal liability from
servicers for any decisions they
make to renegotiate the total
value of these mortgages.
I think there's considerable
doubt as to how much
activity--how much positive
activity--that would generate,
but there's no downside and
potentially some upside.
There's also another
interesting problem in this
area, which is many subprime
mortgages,
probably more than a third,
have second liens against them
that are serviced by somebody
other than the original
originator.
Anybody's good plan for working
these things through where you
reduce the value of the house
is, in effect,
going to wipe out that second
mortgage.
But, it is going to require the
consent of that second mortgage
and that second mortgage doesn't
have any very strong incentive
to give consent.
There's a long and dubiously
honorable financial tradition of
being paid to be a holdout.
How one handles that is a
potentially serious problem,
not least because it's
financially and economically
advantageous to do so.
People who are good at being
holdouts are likely to acquire a
substantial number of these
second mortgages and so the
holdout rights will be exercised
more skillfully than they would
be by their current holders.
I guess my reaction is--to your
question is--can the capital
markets handle it?
Yes, at a price and the price
will be that de facto in
this environment.
The demand curve for equity
slopes downward,
so if a lot of equity needs to
be raised,
the price will be lower than if
a small amount of equity needs
to be raised.
So, shareowners of these
institutions are not wrong to be
hoping to reduce the amount of
capital they have to raise.
That is rational behavior on
their part, but it may not be
desirable from the point of view
of the system.
Student: Then the
question would be,
I guess, where would they have
to take capital from in order
for lenders to do something?
Professor Larry Summers:
I don't think we have a--I
think, with the trillions of
dollars sitting in sovereign
wealth funds with a very large
volume of assets that are held
by pension funds,
and endowments,
and life insurance companies,
I don't think one needs to fear
that if $200 billion more in
capital was infused into U.S.
financial institutions that
somehow there would be a
generalized--relative prices
would adjust in various ways.
But, I think the least of the
concerns is that somehow we'd
have a general shortage of
capital for other purposes.
I think there is a--this is a
tricky subject,
in the sense that everybody's
got the same idea,
which is that they want to be
the last dollar of equity in
because you want to be in after
the dilutions rather than in
before the dilutions.
So, there's the concern that,
when you speak of large needs
for capital, that the incentive
to be a partial solution may not
be that great.
On the other hand,
the strategy of sort of
deception--we only need a little
and then we'll be done--also is
probably not a strategy that can
be carried on very successfully
for a long period of time.
That's why somewhat more
comprehensive,
somewhat larger approaches to
capital raising would,
it seems to me,
be desirable.
Gus?
Student: You were
mentioning that additions to the
agreed short-term stimulus
package might be warranted.
What would you include in such
a second package?
Professor Larry Summers:
I suspect there should be a
contingency plan that is in
place to give more rebates
during the tax filing season
next spring that somebody can
decide to pull the trigger on or
not to pull the trigger on late
next fall,
as we see where the economy is.
There should be some
supplementation of unemployment
insurance and food stamps and
there should be--almost
certainly be--some effort to
reduce the pro-cyclicality of
the state and local sector,
which because of balanced
budgets and less tax
collections, spending of all
kinds is being cut back.
I say "almost certainly"
because there is a bit of a
problem in the history of fiscal
federalism in the United States
in that whenever times are good,
governors cut taxes and
whenever times are bad,
the federal government provides
support to respond to the
emergency.
That's not a terribly healthy
set of arrangements and there
was a lot of tax cutting going
on in the good times.
But on balance,
I think there are a variety of
mechanisms, including Medicaid
reimbursement,
for doing it;
but, doing something for state
and local governments would be
the other piece I would
emphasize.
Yeah?
Student: What do you
think is the main cause of the
housing crisis?
Why did it happen?
Professor Larry Summers:
I think most of positive
feedback mechanisms that I
talked about yesterday were
operative both going up and
going down in the housing and
mortgage security market.
It's not that you can't
understand why people made these
loans.
The truth is that in the period
from the late 1990s through
2006, no matter how crummy the
person--no matter how crummy the
credit of the person--you lent
money to,
you did not get defaulted on.
The reason was that if he
bought a house,
the house went up in value and
he was able to borrow more to
pay you back.
So, the lesson that was learned
was that lending money to
people, even people who didn't
look like they'd be very good
credits,
was a safe thing to do.
Now, ex post,
we can see what the error in
the inference was--that it
presumed the continued strong
behavior of house prices--but
that wasn't completely obvious.
That was less completely
obvious at the time and then you
had various other things.
People made the investments and
they--if you were in the
mortgage business,
you bought mortgages;
you succeeded;
your mortgages went up in value
as risk premiums went down.
Then, you had more capital;
you got paid on the basis of
how much you invested.
With more capital,
you decided to invest more.
So, you had all the kind of
positive feedback mechanisms I
described on the upside and then
you more or less had all those
mechanisms on the downside.
Student: But isn't that
an issue for regulators?
Professor Larry Summers:
Those of an anti--those of a
very strong, if you like,
Chicago School bent make the
point, so let's see who did well
in this situation;
let's see who did badly,
let's see who did reasonably
well in this situation.
Hedge funds--nobody much
regulates them;
they seem to have done okay.
Individuals--some of them got
to--some of them got in trouble
but some of them got loans on
terms that weren't very
attractive;
that wasn't so bad.
Who really made a huge mess?
Well, the big money center
banks made a huge mess.
Who's most extensively
regulated?
Well, the big money center
banks are most extensively
regulated.
I get it; we need more
regulation--is this sort of
Chicago argument and it should
give one--I don't think it's the
end of the subject.
I think, it probably doesn't
point in the right direction at
the end of the day,
but it's not a point to be
taken lightly.
Since I like the spirit of your
observation, here's another
observation in the spirit of
yours.
So, all these banks lost a lot
of money;
who made money?
Well, a ton of the gain that is
opposite the banks loss is a
bunch of relatively poor people
who sold their houses for
substantially more than they
otherwise would have because of
the bad credit that the
financial sector was prepared to
give.
I think the thing you have to
say is that there are a fair
number of people who are having
to explain to their children why
a policeman is knocking at the
door and telling them they have
to leave within six hours
because they signed documents
that they didn't understand and
that weren't explained to
them--that locked them into an
arrangement that was,
for them, going to be highly
problematic.
You can call it predatory
borrowing and you can explain
how they lived in a house,
in a sense, rent-free for a
significant period of time;
but, I think it would be
mistake to discount the trauma
that has been imposed.
But, there is a sense in which
more regulated entities have
performed worse and suffered
more than less regulated
entities.
Last question?
Student: How does our
current crisis compare with
Japan's since the 1990s?
Professor Larry Summers:
Look, I think there are
structural similarities between
our problem and Japan's problem.
I think there are a variety of
reasons to think that the bubble
was substantially greater in
Japan.
I think, if one compares U.S.
policy in the last nine months
with Japanese policy between
1989 and 1992,
we are acting with
substantially more
aggressiveness to get in front
of the problem.
U.S.
regulators, fortunately from my
perspective, have been very
resistant to what was a major
Japanese idea,
which was mark assets in ways
that will--that it is thought
will--contribute to confidence
rather than in ways that reflect
market realities.
I think that the rather
arbitrary accounting that was
pursued as a major tool of
policy in Japan inhibited a
great deal of necessary
adjustment.
That said, while I think the
probability is low,
one can't rule out the kind of
situation that developed in
Japan.
I think we do--I think these
issues of levels of capital in
troubled financial institution
are very important issues.
One way of responding to an
externality is with a subsidy.
The idea of subsidizing
institutions to raise capital
seems quite untenable in the
context of the institution's
shareholders holding onto their
shares.
So in a way,
we operate a system where the
government can't infuse capital
into an institution until the
situation is very far gone,
but once the situation is very
far gone, it is very far gone.
I don't think it's
inconceivable that the
government will have to infuse
capital into institutions on a
significant scale in the course
of this crisis;
but, I don't think we're ready
yet to start planning for Nordic
style or Mexican style,
or Japanese style socialization
of the financial system,
though I wouldn't--I think that
probability is very low.
I wouldn't preclude that as a
possibility and I think,
in retrospect,
it came significantly later in
Japan than would,
in retrospect,
have been ideal.
Thank you very much.